oh I come to this video playing Grand
Master fari not for we nature whatever
from Italy no name or anything very high
rating 25 yeah but hard to guess it's a
leave only let's say 10 to 15 years ago
they they didn't have many grandmasters
nowadays they have quite a substantial
um figure of gm's okay so we have as
image until who unsure about this move
order here do you play if I here let's
play you form yeah this is so a slightly
old-fashioned way to convert the sameish
as black it's not not very popular
nowadays some sometimes bit passive
I'm going to grab all the space that i
can get here nigeria stage 4
mmm hey Troy probably I'm ahead on the
clock mark this on your own calendars
all right he is tried for how to play
quick counter play very understand oh ok
let's just take it not I'm not sure yeah
something like that at least I don't
have much choice at the moment at least
Queen Queen d3 Bishop e3 I don't really
believe that this is good what he's
doing but I can also just play Bishop d3
what is the big point of all this Bishop
g4 yeah even if always good yeah I don't
know that's some hard to save
186 I can play a five this is the main
problem fear is 62 to further um to
further open up I just play 500 resigns
if I've and b6 I think it's time for
yeah maybe you can do this kind of prep
move but you need to sacrifice very
shortly ok
maybe I should have played some proof
like to goof it was clear that he is
going to sec now otherwise it's just
just two lost this position so he needed
to sacrifice
yeah queen of two of course hmm
yeah this is still tricky of course yeah
I really should have played a
prophylactic muth then this is probably
complete nonsense sacrifice and this is
hmm I don't know at least it feared some
it feels like a complicated and kingdom
right age to as well
and I g2h mmm yeah I cannot come
calculate this yeah now add this was bad
I should have played see for this is um
at least at least tricky check with them
some other move that's probably just
winning four wide some prophylactic news
hmm yeah what a shame you can play 93
okay 93 I can play night f5 maybe yeah
95 wow what a wacky position
try at least I didn't expect this move
okay I didn't even see that he can go
there wow wow I completely overlooked at
that this is even even according to the
chess rewards check what the heck
check
can go back to deform simply
okay now Jessie Roxy one have this is
this even okay yeah I just like reason I
just gave away a control point here by
playing playing see for this is not not
working at all for black white is just
completely winning and ce4 is just
idiotic I just I just need one good move
here to prevent him from sucking on g4
down a chive or something and then
resides basically you can just you can
fish play for something night f4 or
something but it's it's just just not
possible comp is on + 4 if you have any
doubts I just played this too quickly
just them I mean it's not about
objective play Bishop g4 is still not
good for like it's still winning for
white but it's it's tricky again and
it's blitz chess so damn white is still
winning but it did it gets tricky candy
two words the move this is so this is
winning for what according to the
computer but yeah it's already tricky
while if I don't allow the sacrifice
it's just just over it's just two points
and you can never play a six let's let's
consider this for a moment computer
plays Knight f8 and analysis which is
the same as resigning can quickly check
this one
yeah just just waiting for white what
can you do just winning this piece
basically all i needs to go to v8 and
then I just protects you three and it's
over okay you can still try to try to
find some tricks and blitz but it's such
a scone v5 is some it's not working
simply at least the second porn sec is
completely unsound around here you you
just try to play for tricks what a shame
yeah thanks for watching anyway